yeah welcome to this video playing Jamie
taja jammy Dodger I got it right I
always played the comp card somewhere
against this guy we had the pun off yeah
I know he had some some some disaster
with this recently maybe he know him ya
know he actually had had a look at this
opening screen have six queen bee 6am
right yeah Quinn v6 I forgot my own at
my own video serials I covered this in
this series for the ICC in a German
language wow this is a very
materialistic move he somehow has a soft
spot for keeping us know keeping his
King in the middle ends and stuff like
that okay how to how to punish that e6
or 96 problem I really have a good
development here yeah of course just
never develop your psets must be crazy
ok so I'm not g4 right threatening on f2
what
what's the big point I don't understand
any of his moves
Queen f2 King be one wasn't too too
great probably but what is he doing now
guess I'm all this guy it's got those
disasters against me all the time like
reasons nobody you cannot take that you
cannot play we should see one I mean
this cannot believe this is really
really asking for it should see one
maybe with extreme precision you can
still um still keep this position going
i mean this this is coming with the
check with the tempo and and
everything's out i mean black will get
some attack here it's pretty clear and
FYI don't think you can you can afford
that here it's it's it's tricky to move
computers already on minus 2 with the
with this line yeah it's just an
automatic attack with with opening up
the position edits you've got the pieces
on aggressive squares and this is not
great and the king you cannot play with
shop c1 i think and some the the best
move probably in this position is some
this long castles covering the pawn and
then black and black black bull will
snatch on f2 and it's very complicated
but interesting you have very short game
but yeah thanks for watching